you really don't know who I am Jeannie
wishes land
none of that ringing about
[Music]
everyone loves the goopy blue genie from
Aladdin but in both the animated version
and the live-action remake we find out
that he's got some limits
check out these 10 strict rules that the
genie must follow hey can you make me a
prince no extra wishes when the genie
appears to his new masters he gives them
some guidelines he tells them that there
are a few things they cannot wish for
most of the people who rub the genies
lamp are a lot like Jafar they are power
hungry and wanted cheat the system but
they are not allowed to wish for more
wishes the genie has a max of 3 wishes
that he can grant to any person he
wishes to be exact an X may on the
wishing for more wishes this keeps
things pretty fair can you imagine if
Jafar had unlimited wishes things would
have gotten even worse we are super glad
that this is one of his rules
tiny living space genie is naturally a
pretty big guy of course he can shrink
himself if he needs to but one of the
rules that he has to follow makes things
pretty cramped the genie must live
inside the lamp have you seen the size
of that thing
it's tiny you might think that maybe
it's magically enhanced to be bigger on
the inside but in the new live-action
movie the genie says several times that
his living space is itty bitty it's been
around for at least 10,000 years we
can't imagine living in a place that's
small for that long it brings a whole
new meaning to tiny houses no love
stories one of the other rules that the
genie sets for his masters is a really
great one he can't make anyone fall in
love with anyone else we are so glad
that this is a roll love is a super
personal emotion it would be very bad if
the genie forced someone to love a
person that was bad for them can you
imagine being forced to love a person
you hated this may have made Ladin's
life a little more complicated because
of jasmine but jasmine is a strong
independent woman she could make up her
own mind
what just happened show off the genie
has some amazing abilities and mostly he
only uses them to grant three wishes but
he has some wiggle room when it comes to
showing off he is able to put on a big
display of his powers for Aladdin he
does this to basically show Aladdin what
he's capable of Aladdin was pretty
skeptical at first he didn't really
understand what Genie was the genie was
able to sing his song and show off a lot
of his magical abilities and in the
movie he was able to make a nice cozy
tent for Aladdin while he decided what
to wish for I could just thank you a
prince so he can use his powers outside
of wishes that is meant for showing off
to his new master
three wishes max there is a limit of
three wishes per person but what if
someone gets three wishes and loses the
lamp and somehow finds themselves owning
it once again this happened to Aladdin
he still had one wish left when Jafar
took the lamp but when Aladdin got the
lamp back his wishes didn't reset even
though he stopped being the genies
master he still only had one wish left
this keeps people from going totally
wish crazy if you got three new wishes
every time you became the master you
could hand off the lamp to your besties
and they could give it back to you for
three more wishes but the genie doesn't
work like that undo the wishes the genie
is able to do some things of his own
free will
and one of those is taking wishes away
when the old master is no longer a
problem
Jafar uses his third wish to become
all-powerful like a genie but then he
gets bound to his own lamp the good
genie then fixes all the problems too
far cause he brings peace back to
Agrabah and sins Jafar's lamp into the
desert and no one had to use a wish to
make this land once the master is no
longer an issue
the genie can use his powers to set
things right thank goodness no zombies
the third rule that the genie tells his
masters is probably the most important
he cannot bring anyone back from the
dead and this is such a good rule the
genie is not a director of a scary movie
he is not going to have a bunch of
zombies walking around that would be
terrifying it can be super sad to lose
someone
love but using one of your wishes to
bring them back simply won't fly with
the genie overall this is a good rule
for the Masters of the Lamb sign a
contract the genie says that the only
way to grant a wish is if the master
rubs the lamp when they make it but in
the new movie we find out that this
isn't exactly the case Jafar throws of
lighting to the sea the genie shows up
just in time but he can't save Aladdin
without him making a wish but Aladdin is
unconscious the genie draws up a
contract with a wish written into it he
takes a widens hands and makes him sign
it then he's able to grant the second
wish thanks genie secondary wishes
sometimes wishes might require some
extra help from the genie this happens
to Aladdin he wishes to become a prince
but this requires a lot more work than
just dressing up Aladdin and giving him
a parade in the new movie we definitely
see a bunch of secondary wishes he gives
a lot and dancing powers to show off to
Jasmine it's all a part of making him
seem like a prince and then Jasmine
demands to know where Agrabah is oh it's
wonderful
genie waves his little finger and makes
a curb appear on her map these extra
bits of magic are allowed because they
are part of the first to wish only one
way to freedom
but genie might have all these magical
powers but he is not free at all he is
forced to live forever serving others
who may or may not be evil and the genie
wants nothing more than freedom he is
bound to his lamp by magical bracelets
the only way to freedom is if one of his
masters wishes him to be free thankfully
Aladdin is a good friend he uses his
last wish to set the TV free Gd you're
free
Bastien always gets us right in the
fields
what would your three wishes be if he
found to the magic lamp let us know in
the comment section thanks for watching
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe see you next
time on the things
[Music]